[Music]
it's the patreon folks by the way
speaking of what i saw russell howard
last night you ever see that guy no
killer english guy british comic funny
stuff i think he's doing colbert hmm
killer that was shot
i thought gotham oh look out for him
yeah check him out russell howard
i'd i'd heard of him but seeing him live
was i don't know why i started with that
that was a weird word
all right it's the patreon baby
let's go yeah it's good to see you man
yeah you too we've been drinking and uh
yeah we got a i like that shirt what's
this going thank you how about this uh i
wore a chubbies shirt i tagged them they
sent me a ton of [ __ ] chubbies chubbies
it's called chubbies that's the name of
the clothing brand pull up chubbies they
they what's the point of it
like the whole thing is to make you look
trim or something or what is it i don't
know why they're called chubbies see
there it is but
they make they start out with shorts
because short shorts became cool their
underwear is called floppies
it's kind of like
frat boy i want to say but
it's super cool clothes and they they
branched out to shirts jackets pants
and they sent me a ton of stuff and i'm
i'm loving it all right and they're
chubbies hook me up too yeah hook up sam
they sent me a bunch of [ __ ] in time for
the virgin islands so i got to wear all
this like cabana wear out there feel
that
oh that's nice it's nice you can really
breathe it pops yeah yeah it's nice i'll
tell you it's stretchy stretchy all
right it's all right yeah should we do
some some questions here oh yeah
and remember to uh email us that we
might be drunk pod at gmail.com there
you go jokes peeves drinks wrecks
uh [ __ ] a news story who gives a [ __ ]
i mean whatever hell yeah dennis if you
could go anywhere on vacation for a week
where would you go great question
anywhere
that's tough um so oh is are we
eliminating comedy here yes comedy's out
of the equation you're not gonna do a
show uh
i mean i love amsterdam i know it's a
hack answer but i love i've been there
like five times and every time i get
there then i hit those canals and like
the anne frank area
i just get
i just get like filled with euphoric
feelings i love that look
those danes
i don't know where i would go i'm
thinking i mean [ __ ]
paris is a classic maybe like somewhere
yeah paris is classic maybe like japan
oh that's a good one because that's a
far one and when are you going there
exactly yeah that's not bad i don't know
i'm trying to think of something good i
mean [ __ ] is it argentina would be great
uh argentina i feel like you get good
bang for your buck over there you eat
well you drink good wine steak
23 bucks
i like it that's kind of that sounds
good to me i like it's tough for me to
like think of a vacation without comedy
yeah
i know
but we need that baby oh you you look
refreshed
yeah i feel refreshed and i couldn't
wait to get back too which is always a
good feeling on vacation you know when
you're in new york you're like god the
city it's cold the homeless the subway i
want to kill myself i hate it i'm busy
and then you you're sitting there like
on a lawn chair on the beach and you're
like this is great and then three days
go by and you're like i'm ready yeah
let's do it i'm the phone is at 100
yeah i'm with you but yeah where would i
go paris is
pull up some photos of prague i always
hear about prague i'm a big city guy i
hate nature
so like all these people like i'd go
hike in the himalayas i'm like ah that
sounds like work yeah give me a
like a dive bar in prague that looks
[ __ ] fun oh
man imagine having a buzz walking down
there at sunset
whoo
gal on your maybe greece maybe greece
greece you go to although look i'm a
city guy but one of those little [ __ ]
islands and yes yeah mykonos mykonos
something like something like that where
you're like really i like it
off the grid yeah i feel like you might
get some work oh look at that [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] out of here i wanna [ __ ] that
water right now yeah i'm gonna stick my
dick in that water hell yeah it's blue
it's clear the buildings look so white
and clean oh my god
you could eat food yeah you could eat a
[ __ ] filet right off that floor look
at that i know i just see bourdain there
with a with sunglasses on and a cold
beer
mykonos where it all happens
[Laughter]
wow that does look nice all right good
question dennis what do you got oh geez
joker 81 i guess joker81 what do you
think about burke chrysler on his new
game show what's the show is this the
one on t on tnt with like snoop and
everything i think it's tbs and it's
it's
it's crazy that he has the time to do a
[ __ ] game show this guy's got eight
points so funny that he's got a tv show
and it's probably the least popular
thing he does i know right that's he
does he does so many things i mean his
podcasts are huge two bears one cave is
gigantic his podcast is pretty big
uh
yeah what is the game show called i
can't think of the name of it
go big
yeah there you go snoop dogg that's
pretty cool yeah
boy did anyone branch out of rap better
than snoop dogg i mean the guy was like
a gang member and and [ __ ] compton
and now he's like ice cube he's working
with i guess ice cube yeah he was in a
couple kids movies
yeah but no snoop really [ __ ] did it
yeah once he came out with a weed
cookbook i was like all right he's he's
in the mainstream he's a weed cookbook
yeah who buys a cookbook anymore i don't
i was watching that julia child
documentary you're the one who told me
to watch that right very good yeah yeah
so i watched it on the flight there
because of you
it is good it's it's inspiring yeah and
i was kind of like she broke because of
a cookbook that first off took her 12
years it's hilarious to think that
you're 12 years on a french cookbook i
know it's ingredients imagine if that
flops
well there goes my life i guess good
point but
yeah i was listening to that because i
was watching that because of you and i
was thinking about that and like man
it makes you realize like cookbooks it's
a cool thing to do but like
think about how big you could be on just
like tick tock if you get like a good
camera guy right and you just like cut
it up the right way you you change your
life you put a cookbook no one ever sees
it ever no one sees it yeah what what do
you do it's all on google maybe you're
in a store or like a cool store in
vermont or something yeah maybe but like
but that's not why we're trying to you
know yeah
cookbook that's like the unequated
that's like the hbo special and tick
tock is like the youtube special right
right exactly
yeah maybe getting a cookbook is like
getting a record player you know it's
kind of kitschy
that's true but yeah it is it seems very
out of date